i want to say right up front the joe
rogan show
isn't over in fact it's most likely
still the number one show in the world
i'm just afraid the joe rogan experience
will soon become the spotify experience
has anyone else stopped watching his
show ever since he moved
over to spotify i know i can't be the
only one
i will be honest with you though i'm not
exactly sure why i'm making the video
i guess i just want to give my thoughts
on a show that i know i have
loved for so long now i'm sure i will
sound like one of those fans who get
upset whenever things change but what
can i say
his show does feel different it feels
like it's missing something but maybe
that's just me
now for those of you that don't know i
have been a fan of the joe rogan
experience for nearly a decade
i started watching his show when he was
still recording episodes out of his
house
and out of the back of the ice house
with brian redband
i have seen his show go through a lot of
changes over the years but i think we
are finally witnessing the end of an
era i have to say it i do miss the old
days of jre
i actually made a video about this
around four months ago right before joe
rogan left los angeles
in that video i went over some of my
concerns about the direction his show
was heading in
i hate to say it but it looks like i was
right at least as of right now
but who knows maybe things will change
right after i upload the video
first i just want to say i don't blame
joe for leaving los
angeles or even making the deal on
spotify if they were offering me
over a hundred million dollars i most
likely would have done the exact same
thing
however i almost guarantee joe won't
accept another offer like this again
i would even go as far as to say joe
might end up
regretting this deal long before he sees
it through
he has to be aware of the effect this is
having on his audience
i think it all started when joe moved
into his new studio
all you have to do is go through the
comment sections on joe's videos and you
can see what the fans think about his
show these days
i'll be honest with you i don't like his
new studio either
but it doesn't bother me that much i
never watch his show to see what's
happening in the background
in fact i loved his first episodes when
red band had bubbles and snowflakes on
the screen
that didn't matter to me i was always
there for the conversation
but now that is even starting to change
one of my favorite things about the joe
rogan experience was the fact that he
would always have his friends on the
show
now don't get me wrong i love when joe
has on guys like elon musk
graham hancock and even alex jones i
like when he has on a very interesting
or even a controversial guest but my
favorite episodes are when joe has his
friends on the show
these are the conversations that feel
the most natural because he's speaking
to guys he knows and loves the most
i think it's the main reason why so many
fans fell in love with the show
it almost felt as if you were a fly on
the wall listening to a conversation
amongst your own friends
ever since joe went to texas he hasn't
had any of his best friends on the show
i know he did recently have on bill burr
but i'm referring to his very close
friends like joey diaz
eddie bravo brian callan burke kreischer
segura and so many more now i know the
lockdown has had a major effect on who
joe has on the show
but i feel like they could still get
this done one way or another
like i said in my video four months ago
i'm afraid we have seen the end of an
era
not only has the joe rogan experience
been affected but so have most of the
shows by his friends
most of them don't even live in the same
state anymore joey diaz ended the church
of what's happening now
and he moved back to his home state of
new jersey now unless they record an
episode over skype
i don't think we will see joey diaz on
joe rogan's show anytime soon
i mean let's face it joey diaz would not
even drive across los angeles to go on
another show
so how likely is it that he will fly
across the united states to do a show
joe rogan's other best friend brian
callan no longer does his own show the
fighter and the kid
i know he does have a new show about
conspiracy theories but i have no
interest in watching that show
if i want to see anyone talk about
conspiracy theories it would have to be
a show hosted by the lovable
and crazy eddie bravo as of right now
brian callan is blacklisted in the media
if he can't even go on his own show
anymore then what are the chances joe
will have him on his show
as far as i know joe rogan hasn't even
mentioned brian cowan's name in months
honestly
maybe joe did say something about it and
i just missed it
but i feel like he has stayed silent
about brian callan's accusations
speaking of eddie bravo i don't know
when joe will have him on again either
it was becoming very obvious joe rogan
was getting sick of eddie's rants on the
show
now that they're living in different
states i would be surprised if we see
him on the joe rogan experience
more than once a year and i already know
some jre fans don't like eddie bravo but
i
do now i don't agree with all his wacky
theories but i
enjoy hearing them and hearing joe
debate him whenever he was on
by the way that's another thing that has
changed about joe
he used to believe all the same
conspiracies that he does
i think that's one of the reasons he and
eddie became friends they both shared a
love for martial arts
and conspiracy theories whenever joe had
him on the show
they would go deep down the rabbit hole
for hours and hours
but now joe argues against everything
that he once believed himself
you can even tell that sometimes eddie
feels somewhat betrayed by this
but i really don't want to go down that
road either at least not right now
chris delia is another one who fell off
the face of the flat earth
now i wouldn't say him and joe rogan
were great friends anyway
but he would go on his show every now
and then and he would go on the fighter
in the kid very often
but him and brian callan are now in the
same boat it doesn't seem like
anyone wants anything to do with them
anymore but i will say it again
who really knows as soon as i upload
this video someone will most likely go
on someone else's show
and make me look stupid i know joe rogan
did recently go on ari shaffir's show
but how often does that happen once
every five years
either way the days of old are now gone
now that most of them have left la we
won't be seeing them hanging out with
each other like we used to
the joe rogan experience has been sucked
into a black hole
you can't even go back and watch any of
the old episodes on this website anymore
either
if you go to joe rogan's channel you
will most likely see that all of his old
episodes have been taken down
the only thing that gets uploaded here
on youtube now are the short clips from
the episodes that are uploaded
exclusively to spotify
now what's funny is joe keeps trying to
get everyone to go over to spotify by
saying it's free
but guess what joe your show was always
free so it's not like that's some big
incentive to download spotify
and this leads me to the next reason why
i think joe will end up regretting his
deal with the company
i think joe's numbers have been down way
down as i said before all you have to do
to get a feel for joe's audience is go
look at the comments under his videos
i know i'm not the only one who hasn't
been watching his show on spotify
now unless he has on one of his old
friends or a very interesting guest
i really don't see myself downloading
the app to watch his show anymore
in my opinion one of the worst things
about this is the fact that it goes
against a lot of what joe used to stand
for
all you have to do is go back and watch
any of joe's old episodes
especially when he had on any of the
guys from opie and anthony
he would always talk about how great it
was to run your own show
because you could say whatever you want
without having to face any real backlash
but even that has changed now i'm sure
some of you saw the headlines
spotify actually wanted to edit some of
the things joe was saying
some of their other employees were even
willing to go on strike
because they didn't want joe to be able
to get away with saying whatever he
wanted
not only that but joe has even started
to issue apologies for things he said
and we all know this is only because of
his deal on spotify
hello everybody i need to make an
apology and a retraction
um i said something on the podcast with
douglas murray about people getting
arrested
for uh lighting fires he never would
have done this
if he were still on his own even one of
his best friends joey diaz said
he felt sorry for joe for having to
issue that apology
he said things were good when we were in
the basement
but once you take that spotify money you
basically have to act like you care
about others feelings
now i won't say exactly what uncle joey
said but let's just say he was
disappointed in joe poor joe rogan he
put the apology up
they would tell him go because he was
that's hard for my dog
yeah my heart goes out to him he had to
put an apology up things are good in the
basement dog
once you take that spotify money
he knows the old days are over even
sober october has unfortunately come to
an end
what else can i really say that hasn't
been said already i will say this again
though
i don't blame joe for taking the money
this has allowed him to set up his
family for generations
however now that he's got the big check
i don't think we will see him do another
deal like this again
he was already making great money from
the show so he doesn't really need the
money
i would almost guarantee that joe would
rather have his entire audience back
again
than another full check in the future
what do i know though
i can't say what i would do if i were in
the same situation
it's easy for me to say all this because
i'm not the one being offered that kind
of money
hopefully one day joe is able to have on
some of his old friends again
it would be nice to see them all in the
same room together
for now i guess i will just keep
watching some of my other favorite shows
like burr and chrysler show and segura
and chrysler's show
now there are about a hundred other
shows that i watch but i don't want to
sit here and name every single one
anyways let me know your thoughts on all
of this i know some of you are fans of
these shows as well so i would like to
see what you have to say
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching the video i hope you all have a
great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you